I saw you worked with sugar-free how was
that he's [ __ ] crazy he's a wild
[ __ ] yeah he's ridiculous he's like
he's he's out there he's a he's dope but
he's out there yeah I've heard that
about him like he's just like a sh like
I wouldn't say
you know like when you meet certain
artists you're like oh you're out there
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah he's
really himself yeah when I uh I only met
him once and this was like 2010 and he
was walking through the Planet Hollywood
in Vegas with two [ __ ] on leashes
what yeah and I was like well this is
great this is exactly what I'd hoped to
see when sugar-free walked by me [ __ ]
nuts that's crazy yeah no he's crazy to
work with and [ __ ] he's got a lot of
energy he's always like plant like it's
just he's wild bro he's wild how was he
a big influence on you at all when I was
younger I like dodoing a skunk yeah what
else did I [ __ ] with I [ __ ] with uh all
of his [ __ ] man like so what you going
doing what do you want to get like you'd
rather give you my [ __ ] he was
Monumental to me when I was younger him
and Snoop Dogg and [ __ ] like so working
with him was like a dream bro it's crazy
like just even like he reached out he's
like hey let's do it we got a project
dropping on the 23rd
four or five songs just me and him
that's fire so yeah he you know he's
like a he's like an older crazy or me to
a certain degree you know what I'm
saying except for you're in a committed
relationship and I mean he's married now
do you know do you know that why that
[ __ ] did that I feel like because of me
oh really I influenced that [ __ ] to
settle down I influence you sugar-free
you don't gotta admit that [ __ ] [ __ ]
but you you big bro but I'm kicking
around you and he was like man I I just
settled down life might be great this is
kind of cool I don't want to give you my
[ __ ] anymore I want to keep her for
myself I'd rather keep my [ __ ]
We're not gonna share anymore yeah God
yeah yeah no I think I influenced that
[ __ ] with that [ __ ] because I would
talk to the [ __ ] on the phone for two
three hours and he'd just be he's a good
he's a good guy though sugar-free shout
out sugar